معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري اهلا بك وليد اخر التحديثات
وتفاصيل بخصوص حصيله قتلى اسرائيل في هذه
الحرب وايضا اخر المواقف والتصريحات بهذا
الخصوص يبدو ان العدد الذي اعلنه الجيش
الاسرائيلي صباح اليوم مرشح لزياده نهار
هذا اليوم هو اعلن عن اربعه قتلى في صفوف
قواته بينهم ثلاثه ضباط من سلاح الهندسه
ضباط في السلاح في الاحتياط وقد قتلوا في
معارك ووقائع في جنوبي ووسط قطاع
غزه السبب بان العدد يبقى مرشحا للزياده
هو ان المصادر الاسرائيليه نقلت عن مصادر
الجيش بان يوم امس وصف بانه كان الاقسى
والاصعب في المعارك الدائره في قطاع غزه
منذ بدايه الهجوم البري الاسرائيلي في ال
26 من اكتوبر الماضي وكانت المشافي قد
اشارت الى انها تلقت امس او استقبلت نحو
19 ضابطا وجنديا مصابا واشير قبل قليل الى
وجود ايضا ضابطين كبيرين قد اصيبا بجراح
خطيره في تلك المعارك بالاعلان عن الاربعه
عسكريين الذين قتلوا يوم امس يكون قد
ارتفع العدد الاجمالي للضباط والجنود
الذين قتلوا منذ بدايه هذا العام في معارك
بقطاع الى ثمانيه ومجمل عدد الجنود
والضباط الذين قتلوا منذ طوفان الاقصى
وبدء الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه في السابع
من اكتوبر الماضي ونحن في اليوم ال95 من
هذه الحرب قد اصبح
514 قتيلا ومن بينهم
186 ضابطا وجنديا قتلوا منذ بدء العمليه
البريه الواضح في الموقف الاسرائيلي
والمعلومات المتسربه حول ما كان ب الامس
ان هناك على الاقل ثلاثه معارك ووقائع كان
قد مني فيها الجيش الاسرائيلي بخسائر
فادحه بالارواح بينها ان مجموعه من الجنود
والضباط كانوا داخل مبنى تعرض للقصف من
قبل كتائب القسام والمقاومه وانهار هذا
المبنى عليهم فخلف قتل وجرحى والموقع
الاخر هو انفجار شاحنه اسرائيليه محمله
بالذخيره وسط مجموعه من الجنود وهي ايضا
ما خلف قتلى وجرحى والواقعه الثالثه كانت
تفجير المقاومه الفلسطينيه عبوات الناسفه
والغام شديده الانفجار باليه مدرعه من نوع
نمر مما اسفر عن مقتل وجرح من كان في
داخلها وهذا يبقي الباب مفتوحا على ان يتم
الاعلان نهار اليوم عن المزيد من القتلى
في صفوف قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي المتحدث
باسم الجيش ومصادره تقول بانه كان بالامس
قد حقق رغم ذلك كله تقدما سواء فوق الارض
او تحتها وانه ضبط مصنعا فيه مخرطه او اله
خراطه هائله كانت تنتج الصواريخ بعيده
المدى التي تطلق على اسرائيل وانه قام
بضبطها وتدميرها وان قواته ايضا اوقعت
عددا كبيرا من القتلى في صفوف المقاومه
الفلسطينيه تحديدا كتائب القسام لكن وسط
هذا كله ووسط السيطره الاسرائيليه على
الجو وقصف كثيف في جنوبي قطاع غزه ووسطه
تمكنت المقاومه الفلسطينيه امس من ان تقصف
وسط اسرائيل تحديدا منطقه تل ابيب الكبرى
والسهل الساحلي الجنوبي الممتد جنوبها
والذي يضم اكثر من 20 بلده ومدينه وقال
الجيش بانه رصد نحو 20 صاروخا اطلقت من
قطاع غزه بهذا الاتجاه وايضا نحو غلاف غزه
ومدينه ديو المتاخمه للحدود وانه اعترض ع
من هذه الصواريخ بينما سقطت صواريخ اخرى
في مناطق غير ماهوله في محيط منطقه تل
ابيب عندما نتحدث عن تل ابيب الكبرى نحن
نتحدث عن منطقه تصل مساحتها الى نحو 1500
ك م مربع وهو ما يساوي تقريبا اربعه اضعاف
مساحه قطاع غزه وهي منطقه مقتضى ايضا فيها
اكثر من 4 مليون من الاسرائيليين وربما
اكثر هذه المنطقه تعتبر هي القلب
الاسرائيلي بالاساس وفيه كافه المواقع
السياديه وايضا الاستراتيجيه وعلى نطاق
واسع الاسعاف الاسرائيلي قال بانه لم يسجل
اي اصابات والدفاع المدني قال بانه لم تكن
هناك اضرار لكن الاسرائيليون وعلى صعيد
مصادرهم الامنيه والعسكريه
وتقديراتهم قالوا بان قدره المقاومه
الفلسطينيه على اطلاق صواريخ بعي عيده
المدى نحو منطقه تل ابيب مؤشر على ان هذه
المقاومه ما زالت تملك قدرات صاروخيه جيده
ومواصله عمليات القصف وانها ما زالت ان
القسام وقيادته ما زالت تدير الامور في
والمعارك في قطاع غزه بمعنى ان ما كان قد
شاع منذ شهر ونصف واكثر وتردد كثيرا من
قبل الاسرائيليين بانهم يلحظون بدايات
انكسار في كتائب القسام هذا غير دقيق من
وجهه نظرهم ما دامت قادره على القيام
بعمليات قصف ولمد بعيده مثلما كان عليه
الحال يوم امس ومثل ما كان عليه الحال
ايضا ليله راس السنه الجديده حيث كانت قد
قصفت القسام وفي اللحظه الاولى من السنه
من دخول السنه الجديده قصفت ايضا منطقه تل
ابيب وبشكل واسع جدا شكرا لك وليد العمري
مدير مكتب الجزيره كنت معنا من رام الله
m